because right here behind me  we have tania to in the commentary  and she tends to get extremely excited  when she's doing it she stands up  she is yelling and she goes excited  peter we've got company here we're  joined by the oslo studio hey guys  wow  he's the man behind all those interviews  by the way chat wants to know we want to  know do we get another hands interview  today we're hoping so definitely so i  guess i'm talking to both broadcasts  right now but any hans interview is  bound for a good day but we want to see  our top commentators sitting here in her  right element  well this is what it looks like so we've  got our chat  and our game window here and this is our  broadcast and a very big moment here  because love looks like he's in big big  trouble he's managed to get his queen  trapped on a5 uh we're trying to find  the right way ahead for prague here uh  this is a big game i swear as you can  see they are now following also the left  game who is in big trouble